[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
an arrest in a 25 year old cold case you
won't believe
how detectives got their big break he
told dispatch
hey i want to confess to a murder plus
wild unruly courtroom moments
court cam season 3 is out and we're
giving you an inside peek
and jury deliberations in the trial of a
deadly love triangle
who killed this army veteran law and
crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian ross in today for brian
buckmeyer
joined of course by terry austin and we
begin with an alabama cold case that
broke wide open because
of a phone call angenette levy has more
on the story
it was just another day at the police
station one day last week for detective
sean mukhadam until the phone rang and a
man on the other end
wanted to confess to murder i pick up
the phone
you know not really having any
expectation of
what's going to be on the other side and
that's the first thing out of his mouth
is
i killed somebody and i want to confess
and
and tell you the whole story the man on
the phone was johnny dwight whited the
53-year-old told decatur police
detectives that he shot
christopher daly in the head in 1995.
hunters found daley's body a couple of
weeks later his vehicle was found in a
river
detective mukadam said whited confessed
because he's dying and wanted to have a
clear conscience
while giving daley's family some closure
we end up meeting like
like down the road we were kind of
concerned about officer safety so we had
him come to us
and then it was simple as that he just
was ready to tell a story
got in the back of a marked unit i sat
in the front seat of the mark unit in
the passenger seat and he literally
drove us to the crime scene
he's like turn right turn left when we
were at the crime scene he literally
walked us through through every little
step where the victim's vehicle was
parked where the deceased was
um why um and then after we left that
initial crime scene we actually went to
the location where he dumped the vehicle
into the tennessee river
detective mu cotton said that whited and
christopher daly met
shortly before the murders but he
wouldn't comment on the motive
he also said that daley's family is
relieved that an arrest has finally been
made
for long crime daily i'm angenette levy
thanks angenet white's attorney told law
and crime that it's been a strange set
of events but he has a duty to defend
him just as he would any other client
charged with murder crazy statements
from defendants
and wild courtroom moments happen from
time to time
but those moments are exactly what are
all about the a
e network program court cab
here to talk about court cam and the
season three of this hit show is dan
abrams the founder of law and crime and
dan
what can viewers expect this season you
know brian it's going to be a mix
of amazing moments inside a courtroom
there'll be
defendants lashing out they'll be angry
judges they'll also be
inspirational moments there'll be
moments where
a victim's mother expresses forgiveness
to the defendant inside of court
there'll be efforts to escape from
courthouses
um so there is just a
a real diversity in the types of stories
that happen at courthouses but it is
really
all kind of a sense a little peek into
humanity
and you ask yourself if i was in that
situation
what would i do and i think that's one
of the things that really distinguishes
court
cam and the context we provide in some
of the interviews as well
exactly one of the most memorable
moments that i saw was when a defendant
on trial for sexual assault
stormed a prosecutor in the courtroom
dan let's check that out and talk about
it with the back story
after we see the video the jury's
reached a decision
in one of the cases and is about to read
its verdict
in under eight seconds so much has
happened
let's look at it again if you look a
little closer
you can see harding removed something
from inside his sleeve
turns out harding is holding a metal
shank harding storms the prosecutor's
table
headed straight for assistant d.a roth
if not for the quick reflexes of
detective kanan
roth could have sustained serious
injuries
quite a story dan what's behind all of
that well you know the question
a lot of people ask is well how did he
get the shank right
and and it's a very different process
with regard to security
at a courthouse and there they
reevaluated their security after that
incident
then for example going into a jail if he
was going back to jail or to prison
they would certainly put him through a
metal detector but because this was
something where he was
in court um he was able to avoid
that and as a result almost hurt that
prosecutor
you know we've seen a number of cases on
court cam where people end up
you know attacking the prosecutor or
attacking their own attorney
um and you know as you can imagine they
almost never succeed and it certainly
doesn't help
their case or their sentence in any way
and you wonder with all the security
that we see in courtrooms now how that
actually could have happened
well exactly and i think what's what
people forget
is sometimes in smaller courthouses
around the country
they don't have as much security we see
a number of cases where there's an
escape
from the courthouse in a relatively
small courthouse
and you see a bailout sort of watch the
person go out it's not a murder case
it'll be a lesser crime and they then go
and catch the person
they know a lot about these people they
know where they live
so we watch the video of them escaping
and people chasing them
to some degree but then once they get
out you think oh they're home free
they're not
they end up getting caught
right it's a high drama as we see in
these court camp episodes it's really
fascinating
yeah i mean and that is the point it is
it is the drama and i think
one of the important things brian about
what we're doing on court camp
is we're not just providing clips right
it's not just a clip show
the ideas provide context around the
story
explain exactly what was happening why
was it happening
and then talk to some of the people
involved
all right well thanks dan very much
court cam season three airing
on the a e networks thanks again dan
abrams thanks brother
there's an update to the fatal shooting
at a protest in kenosha wisconsin
the 17 year old charged with killing two
people and injuring the third
is out of jail on a two million dollar
bail
kyle rittenhouse is facing charges of
intentional homicide
and illegally possessing a gun the
kenosha county sheriff's office says
rittenhouse posted the bond
through his attorney his attorney lynn
wood said that the money was raised
through the help of an actor and a ceo
his attorney claims he fired in
self-defense
still ahead on the law on crime daily a
florida woman charged with shooting a
police officer
called 911 herself and later
the fatal shooting of a man inside his
own apartment
with police body cam video reveals after
the break
[Music]
welcome back we're following two cases
involving officer-involved shootings
first in new york where authorities in
the bronx have released a body cam video
of a man
fatally shot inside his own apartment
terry austin is here with more terri
brian the bronx dis attorney says an
investigation found no criminal
wrongdoing
by two responding officers records show
kowalski treywick
called the fire department in 2019 after
being
locked out of his apartment and worrying
that the food he was cooking
might catch fire his building
superintendent
separately called 9-1-1 saying trey rick
was
harassing tenants firefighters opened
his door
and police arrived minutes later freyrik
was holding
a knife and a stick when officers tased
him he got up
came at them and was shot twice his
mother says he was a loving and
non-violent person
who struggled with mental health
challenges
[Music]
put it down why are you in my home put
it down it's got a knife yeah i know
i don't i got my knife because i'm about
i'm cooking put the knife down
come on put it down put the knife put
the knife down i'm cooking put the knife
down
i just called the fire department
and now to florida where a 9-1-1 call
placed by a jacksonville woman
is at the center of her criminal case
diamonds
ford is accused of shooting a police
officer the officer survived
the jacksonville sheriff's office says
ford fired at them
while they were serving a high-risk
search warrant on her home
she's also facing gun possession charges
but her attorneys say she thought
someone was robbing her home
and didn't know it was police at her
door
take a listen someone's shooting
somebody
you know who's shooting
oh
[Music]
so dramatic joining me now with attorney
dina dahl along with terry austin terry
that phone call really is interesting
the lawyer for her has says that she
acted in self-defense did not though it
was the police
does that uh phone call help bolster
that opinion that
position brian i do think it helps a
little bit
you hear her say in the phone call what
that's the
police like she's surprised so i do
think that she's going to be able to use
that
as a defense because she wasn't clear
who was at her
door and she's going to claim that she
was shooting in
self-defense so yes i think it's going
to help
dina dahl the lawyer for ford used that
phone call to try to get the bail
reduced the judge refused to do that
is that the end can they appeal it
further
they can appeal it further the judge
left room for that
saying if there's more evidence that
comes out
showing that she was unaware that it was
police that
the judge will reconsider the fact that
the neighbors did hear the police
announcing themselves
was evidence that the judge thought was
important and the reason why she didn't
produce the bond
you know for both of you these police
involved shootings continue to plague
the country
they're very tough to make a case
against the officers isn't it
it is brian it's very tough to make a
case because they can claim they thought
that they were in danger when they were
shot at
and dina from your point of view uh when
they think that they're
in that situation where the police say
their self-protection that
really works with jurors doesn't it
almost always
yes it's very difficult i mean there is
the stand the ground laws here that
she'll be able to use to defend herself
but a police officer using typical
protocol gets a lot of deference from a
juror
all right dina doll terry austin thank
you so very much and when we come back
an ohio woman
is now on trial the jury deliberating
her fate on trial for murder
we'll take you inside the courtroom for
past and present lovers
point the fingers at one another stay
with us for
gavel to govern coverage
closing arguments have now wrapped in
the trial of an ohio woman
accused of murdering an army veteran
erica stefanko is accused of making a
fake pizza order
to dominoes luring ashley biggs to her
death
biggs was retired army veteran and
worked as a delivery driver
stefanko's ex-husband chad cobb pleaded
guilty to murdering biggs
and helped to implicate stefanco
prosecutors are arguing
erica stefanko is just as guilty as chad
cobb
she knew what was going to happen that
was their plan that was their purpose
and going near that night
she drove chad to the crime scene
she knew why it was going to happen it
was that custody battle it was
retaliation
she made the call to dominoes that lured
ashley biggs to her death
she followed chad to the cornfield she
waited
at that cornfield for him to dump
ashley's body and the car
in the cornfield she drove chad home to
shower away the evidence
went back to the initial crime scene
with him to clean up the evidence
or to try to clean up the evidence and
he hit with chad
at his grandparents house the torments
in the back of that detached garage
until they were and that's where they
actually were caught by the police
a key piece of evidence was a secret
recording of stefanko made by
the defendant's mother-in-law the
recording was turned over to police
four years after the murder
that was their purpose when they got
there to murder
ashley she says if everything had been
told exactly as it happened
then we'd both be in prison right now i
don't disagree with that
that's totally the truth she also talks
about
he came up with how to do it he executed
almost all of it that's important almost
all of it she acknowledges that she
executed some
the part that he executed went totally
arrived
then he says yeah if if this goes
through
and i can do this i'm going to keep her
skull as a trophy
she's saying that's what they talked
about prior to this happening that goes
to show
she knew what was going to happen they
knew
what was going to happen they had a plan
and that was their purpose for going
there that's the state's case but when
we come back
you'll hear the defense of the woman at
the center of this deadly love triangle
is that recording a confession or a set
up
our analysis in just a few
[Music]
accomplice or innocent that's the
question before an ohio jury
deliberating the fate of a woman on
trial for murder
erica stefanko is accused of murdering
army veteran ashley biggs
prosecutors say the murder was over a
custody dispute between her then
husband chad cobbs and his ex-girlfriend
biggs
but her defense says cobbs and his
mother dragged her into the murder plot
in order to get her thrown in jail
the defense says there are major issues
with the state's witnesses
including chad cobb's daughter who says
she heard the defendant
make the fatal phone call that lured the
victim to her death
well we did all this because we were
afraid of the kids
being adopted out baloney
we asked cindy who's got the kids now
she did
the adoption theory is a scam
those kids were never going to be
adopted out
the whole purpose of chad's scheme is
if i can get ashley put in prison
guess what the way is clear
for my mom to have all the kids
erica knowing that she's got problems
with visitation
pacifies cindy if she
pacifies cindy by telling her what she
wants to hear
she hopes that cindy will then get
control
of who chad the defense says there are
major issues with
the state's witnesses including chad
cobb's daughter
who said she heard the defendant make
the fatal phone call that lured the
victim
to her death well
it would seem that father and daughter
don't have their facts straight
and i'm not going to pick on a 15 year
old
when this incident happened she's
seven years old eight years later
he comes into this courtroom
and describes with
unusual detail about this phone call
yet she tells us she was asleep
the rest of the time
i would submit ladies and gentlemen that
children of any age group
are susceptible to influence
but of course prosecutors got the final
word and said that it's true that chad
cobb
is guilty but so too is erica stefano
but at no time no time in three hours
not once
not a one time does erica stefanko say
i didn't have anything to do with it
i didn't do it i didn't do anything i
didn't make the call i didn't drop him
off
i didn't do anything and he is lying
you never hear that word one time you
will never heard her
say that chad cobb lied you will never
hear her say that cindy cobb lied
she will never say it she never did
so it's really interesting that
the defense in this case is don't
believe
anybody including my client
somebody's got to be telling the truth
right
so terry austin there's no forensic
evidence against erica can the jury
convict without it
yes brian they can but i think it's
going to be extremely difficult to get a
conviction here
like you said there's no forensic
evidence and remember the burden is
beyond
a reasonable doubt and all they have
here are witnesses
who have questionable motives chad
obviously
has a questionable motive he's the one
who did it now he wants dependent on
someone else
his mother wants him to get a lesser
time if at all possible
and she wants to see the children and
the daughter while you know obviously
she's well intended she was very young
at the time
and it's hard for the jury to believe
her so i think
at the end of the day putting everything
on this phone call
is not going to have the jury think
beyond a reasonable doubt
that the defendant is guilty here
well dina certainly that phone call will
be key the jury has asked for the 200
page transcript
of the call what do you think they're
looking at
you know this phone call was actually
three
hours it's a very long phone call so i
imagine they
they want to hear all of it they didn't
hear all of it during the deliberation
there was a phrase that she said in the
phone call which was i did
my part and he didn't have to put a gun
to my head for it
that is going to be very hard for her to
explain away
but perhaps that's why the jury wants to
see all of it
put that phrase into context
were you surprised finally terry that
erica did not take the stand
you know that was interesting because
she went back and forth on that issue
but i think that her
attorney probably convinced her that the
cross-examination was going to be very
difficult
and she decided not to go on the stand
so i'm not surprised generally
defendants
don't take the stand
all right terry austin dean at all thank
you so much for being here and thank you
for joining us here
on the law and crime daily we'll see you
next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you